and many many believe that this response
is humanitarian response has been
massively delayed and is inadequate why
has it taken so long for humanitarian
Aid to arrive to Sudan because
so many of the humanitarian Aid which we
had in stock was looted
all the warehouses wfp
unhcr and others in their four were
looted vehicles from the humanitarian
agencies were looted as the offices of
my own mission uni terms as well as
obviously agencies in most of the towns
of their Force were looted food trucks
were looted wfp lost like 4 000 metric
tons of humanitarian Goods so if all
this is looted you cannot distribute it
four of our humanitarian workers of un
staff in service Distributing Aid were
killed so after the killing of three of
the wfp employees in Northstar 4 wfp
declared a suspension of its operations
and there wasn't things being looted
there wasn't much to distribute so what
we need is to resume humanitarian
activities is a ceasefire a ceasefire
that holds just to ask you about the
ceasefire proposals that we've seen
have they held because all evidence from
the ground has shown that fighting has
continued during those ceasefire periods
none of the ceasefires has been
respected in total they have all been
respected partially and sometimes only
in some locations and not in others
but
it's work in progress you've sat at the
negotiation table with both the head of
the Army and the head of the rsf many
times do you see them coming together to
negotiate again
well in the last two weeks there was
there was no table to negotiate I mean
we we called upon them we spoke to them
on the phone but there was no common
discussion between them before that yes
when we still were speaking about a
political process they were all in their
own signatory civilian military and
non-signatories in different formats now
we have been speaking individually to
them and the idea of getting people
together in a neighboring country which
is supported by the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia the Emirates us UK but also by
the egot countries by South Sudan for
example is to actually bring them
physically together and you need face to
face to agree on some of the modalities
of a ceasefire which is more than just
the Declarations and we are going to
stop the fight and the question that's
often been raised is how could you let
this happen we supported where we could
we facilitated what we could we
facilitated discussions about
critical sensitive issues like
transitional like transitional Justice
For example or even security sector
reform that we have no executive mandate
and even if some people people like to
say that the United Nations has
uh been steering
the political process
was it good or not it's not true it has
been a Sudanese land and Sudan is our
process but you understand that anger
and frustration that people feel towards
this process
I understand the anger and frustration
which people feel towards different
actors and of course some actors who
probably run this political process
against the wall find it easy to then
accuse the foreigners be that the United
Nations or the African Union or eager to
risk to be responsible for that but we
have I mean sometimes I have to explain
it we have not been sitting in the room
when texts have been written we are not
a peacekeeping mission and we are not a
mission with an executive mandate all
decisions in these countries are and
have been Sudanese decisions
the resistance committees at the heart
of the protest movement who really have
a strong presence on ground obviously
have a slogan no partnership no
negotiation what do you make of that is
that sustainable
well the resistance committees had these
slogans after the after the coup and
they have despite their political
differences or the broad spectrum which
say which we are active in and partly
represent they have
mostly
remained commit committed to that but
but many of them have adapted it and
said we are not negotiating with the
military but if political parties and
political movements negotiate with the
military as a result of that in a
process facilitated by the trilateral
mechanism if the result of that is a
return to civilian government we will
support that
we've now seen the UK working with the
US with the Sydney's military with
Sydney's police to get people out to
evacuate them but just a real really
integrated approach how important is
that kind of approach in dealing with
the issues in Sudan and how can that be
done without enabling any one party
it is it is extremely important that
that all actors and you're speaking
about Regional International actors
cooperate here with one another in the
first place both in the messaging to the
warring parties as it were but also in
action like extracting people from
conflict zones evacuating that and and
we have seen here that we have had a few
great signs of of solidarity like it's a
French military flying out
um
United Nations
United Nations staff but also Ingo staff
staff from international
non-governmental organizations out of
Darfur in out of a war zone that is
that's not every nation will be prepared
to so so we were very very grateful to
the French for that were you harmed at
all during the commercials personally I
was I was never harmed but staff members
were staff members were held at gunpoint
staff members were
thrown out of their houses by armed
fighters who took positions there houses
were broken into we had at least one
case of attempted sexual assault on a on
a female staff member and many of the
houses Apartments were hit by stray
shells and bullets and you have to
understand that
for instance the United Nations and for
many of the international
non-governmental organizations and the
embassies khatum is a family Duty
station which means we we have been
there with our families and kids and
therefore many many of the staff wanted
to bring their family into security as
many of our Sudanese friends and
colleagues also do were you shocked by
the sheer scale of the Violence by the
brutality of it
well I think in any outbreak of War you
are shocked what humans are able to who
otherwise and we have been living with
our Sudanese Neighbors
um
are a very very generous friendly people
Sudanese have risked their life to bring
foreigners out of the conflict Zone
because Sudanese no
some of the ways we wouldn't know they
know where it's dangerous where it's
less dangerous but they're still risking
their life and happening risking their
lives for us or for other foreigners to
take them out of the Comfort zones and
and we're very very grateful for for the
support of these Sudanese in retrospect
is there anything you could have done to
prevent this
I'm sure we could have done things
differently but
I guess that's
for
a post-conflict Lessons Learned exercise
which definitely will come
for now I think
we have to concentrate on getting
ceasefire
and doing things differently which is
always possible doesn't necessarily mean
doing things better